further evolution on the efficiency
front is a big issue among car makers
not to be left in the dust BMW has a
wide range of innovations covering
lightweight construction smart energy
management and laser headlights BMW is
looking to maximize overall vehicle
efficiency says spokesman Manfred
portion leader a lightweight concept
with ideal mass distribution and
aerodynamics BMW wants a dynamic drive
system while investing as little energy
as possible and recuperating as much as
possible while such efforts used to
focus on the engine today it's about an
overall concept that includes using
innovative materials for weight
reduction
there's only one if this component has
only half the weight of a conventional
solution stresses lightweight design
chief Carol Kemp it's made of carbon
fiber he's proud of his department's
achievement he's smart and sensible
driving also helps to save fuel and
these days you can get smart assistance
from the car itself when changing gears
for example or when overtaking thanks to
sensors detecting the driving situation
the vehicle accelerates only as much as
is needed to pass safely another crucial
part of the economy puzzle is the
increasing trend towards alternative
drive systems this x5 is a plug-in
hybrid prototype that has an
all-electric range of 30 kilometers
also on board is a smart automatic
transmission that helps select the right
mode the x5s design makes it predestined
for this new kind of powertrain
the x5 prototypes architecture is
comparable to BMWs ActiveHybrid model
says Neil scalpel in front there's the
four-cylinder gasoline engine plus an
8-speed automatic transmission and the
transducer is replaced by an electric
motor the high voltage battery is over
the rear axle to save space when it
comes to key components such as the
electric motor high voltage battery and
power electronics BMW invests heavily in
in-house solutions that ensures all
these parts will meet the specific
requirements of the model Electric run
devices are another fuel guzzler here
for example we have headlamps without
precedent using laser technology the
biggest plus with the headlamps is the
throw has been doubled reveals exterior
lighting chief Thomas Houseman
visibility at night is up to 600 meters
the laser diodes ultimately worked just
like LEDs so they have the same lifespan
at least as long as a car in terms of
efficiency there are 30% better the
optical system around these diodes can
be configured even more efficiently that
saves space weight and energy it's more
with double the output know if it's
scintillating come on Tom it can expel
homespun give expand and AG you spawn on
despite a token performance
efficient mobility is like a jigsaw
puzzle made up of many little parts that
only work when combined in exactly the
right way
you